very pleased to say that joseph joins us
now joseph great to have you on on the
programme just now um
tell us just a little bit about the
journey that has led you from from
kharkiv
all the way to germany
yeah thank you for having me on the show
um first of all i'd like to tell the
viewers that i've been living in ukraine
for about ages and i consider it like my
second home i'm from nigeria
uh the journey wasn't an easy one
because when you've been living in a
place for eight years
uh making the decision to suddenly just
leave
is a really painful one
um on the nights before on the early
morning before i was about to leave i
documented
the situation it was the third day of
the invasion
and i went to the streets and i could
see long lines of people who just wanted
to get food from the supermarket from
the grocery stores long lines of people
who just wanted to
get money from the bank and also from
drugstores
it was a really painful journey it was a
really painful journey
there was a popular saying in english
that no place feels like home and i
really do miss ukraine
well tell us why then um joseph you you
have such affection for the country as
you say you you've been there for what
for for eight years over the course of
eight years you will obviously have made
plenty of friends but you'll also have
got to understand
the ukrainian mindset ukrainian culture
just that little bit better than the
rest of us
yeah
you know
the fact that i lived there for ages i
also speak the russian language so i was
able to you'll find that a lot in my
youtube channel on my youtube video
channel you see me speaking with
ukrainians speaking the russian language
for example eating with strangers
having fun with them and they were like
a family to me and they are like a
family to me so the fact right now that
i'm losing that connection um
right now one of my friends a good
friend of mine who lives in the city of
maryland
i've been trying to contact him for the
past five days right now
i'm unable to contact him i'm hoping the
worst hasn't happened to him because
there there's a lot of bombings there's
a lot of atrocities going on
and it is heartbreaking it is
heartbreaking
it really is and and genuinely i do hope
you managed to make contact with your
friend very very soon joseph but but i
wonder as things stand
with the russians talking up potential
of chemical or biological weapons being
used in the country with with forces
continuing to advance on kiev i just
wonder right now do you think you'll
ever make it back to the country
this is a deep question
because um
this
take your time take your time
ah can i share you one story before i
left
uh i went to the basements
of my neighbors
and i spoke to them
and i could see women crying and they
were like
why we need this
i could see the tired faces
on the people and this was just the
third day the third day of the invasion
using chemical weapons i finished in
medical university in hockey in ukraine
using chemical weapons that's
the atrocity of the highest order
i look forward to going home one day i
look forward to going to ukraine one day
but with everything going on it's almost
like
the hopes are fading
i really do want the ukrainian people to
leave because you know some people are
dying every day
i have no words
joseph i
i i it is it would be utterly obtuse of
me to suggest that there is there is a
silver lining in all of this there is no
silver lining but the one thing that i
think you may well agree with is that
that you and others the reception that
you have had in countries like germany i
mean as i understand that you're you're
actually staying with with one of your
subscribers on youtube
yeah that's the positive thing uh the
beauty of humanity has been
really really really
on the highlight to see i remember when
i first got to poland because when i
left ukraine i just left with two shirts
two trousers
and my shoes and my camera and laptop i
left with the mindset that even if i
lose everything
with my camera and my laptop i can
recover everything back because i'm very
good at storytelling and i can make more
youtube videos and hopefully my audience
grows from there
but something happened in poland i was
because in ukraine it was snowy and i
was with winter socks and when i got to
poland it was a little bit warm so i
began to feel itchy and i didn't really
have some socks to on extra socks on me
and i saw a polish woman and i told her
my problem and she took me to the
supermarket and uh to the clothing sorry
the shopping mall and she actually
bought me some socks and even gave
bought me some other clothes and the
beauty of humanity has just been on the
highlight here
it certainly has will you keep telling
those stories uh joseph um joseph mayor
thank you so much for joining us and i
really do hope you manage to make it
home to ukraine sometime soon my
pleasure thank you